[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hello and welcome back.
So as you recall
in our last lesson,
we went ahead and created
these awesome leaderboards.
But it turns out that they're
pretty boring because nobody
has submitted any
scores to any of them.
And that's because
we haven't hooked up
the logic do that yet.
So, gosh, we should fix that.
Let's do that in this lesson.
So I'm going to stop
our application here--
or I guess it is stopped.
So like in the last chapter, we
created an achievement manager
class that basically
dealt with achievements.
I'm going to go ahead and create
our own leaderboard manager
class.
It's going to be a subclass
of NSObject, and here we go.
Now I'm actually going to
do kind of a hacky thing
that we did in the last lesson,
where we're going to start off
by submitting a hard-coded
string representing
our leaderboard.
I'm doing that mostly just
because I think it's easier
to understand the creation
of our score object this way,
and then we'll go ahead and
clean up in the next lesson.
So this is going to have
one public method-- at least
for now-- and that
will be submit score.
And there's our int that
represents our score
to leaderboard.
And this is our
NSString that's going
to represent our leaderboard ID.
Now to implement this.
There it is.
Now, as you recall in
our achievement manager,
the way we dealt
with achievements
was by creating a GPGAchievement
object that we created
using the class method
achievement with ID,
and we passed in our
unique string associated
with our achievement.
Basically going to
do the same thing
with our leaderboard manager.
Although we don't actually
create a Leaderboard object,
we create a Score
object, and the score
is associated with a
specific leaderboard
that the score's going
to be submitted to.
So let me show you what I mean.
So we're going to call it
GPGScore, score to submit,
equals GPGScore, score
with leaderboard ID.
At this point we
can say score submit
dot value equals the score
that we've passed in.
And then we tell our
score to submit itself
to the leaderboard.
So we would say,
score to submit,
submit score with
Completion Handler.
We get back in our Completion
Handler two things.
We get an Error object
and GPGScore report.
The Error object is
what you would expect,
it would display an error
if something shows up.
The GPGScore report
is fairly interesting.
Let's take a look at this.
So first we'll do if error,
NSLog, "This is terrible."
And we'll have our error
localize message-- there
we go-- localized description.
Otherwise let's just display,
This is your score report."
But if you notice here, we could
actually look at the report
itself.
It's got a bunch of interesting
properties you can see here.
See it's got a few Booleans
for, is the high score
for the local
player for all time?
Is this player's high
score for this week?
Is it the high score for
this player for today?
And if it isn't any
of those things,
if the player had submitted
a higher score earlier,
we can then ask, what
was that high score
that the player
submitted earlier?
And so if we wanted
to, for instance,
bring up our own
notification that said,
hey congratulations,
you beat your old score,
we could do that here.
We could do that by basically
analyzing the score report
and doing something
interesting with it.
In this case, I'm not
going to, I'm just
going to put it out
to the log, but that's
still pretty
interesting, I suppose.
And then I'm going to jump
into our game model here.
And, I suppose, after
we've gone ahead
and incremented and
unlocked our achievements,
this would be good time
to submit our score,
at this point in the
game when we've won.
So it looks like I probably
have to go up here and import
our leaderboard manager.
There we go.
And then, let's create
our own little property
for our leaderboard manager.
Leaderboard manager,
there we go.
And like our
achievement manager,
we can some Lazy Instantiation.
There we go.
Fantastic stuff.
And now we can go
down here and say,
hey self dot
leaderboard manager,
let's submit our score, and this
will be our number of guesses,
to our leaderboard.
And since I am going to be
replacing all this with an Enum
very shortly, I'm
just going to go
and hard code in the leaderboard
ID for our easy difficulty
level.
So let's go find our
developer console here,
and go back into
our leaderboards,
and here's our ID for easy.
So I'm going to copy this.
And we'll just, create it
right here, so there we go.
So now we're all
set up here, let's
run this and see what happens.
Going to get into my game.
I can see that, hey
look, my leaderboards,
they're still, empty
and that's fantastic.
And let's go in and
play an easy game.
Higher than 25.
Hey, look at that, four guesses.
Actually, that's pretty good.
I don't know if I'm going
to be able to beat that.
But we can look at
the log here, and we
can see that we've got
our score report back.
And our Boolean is
reporting, yes, this
is the high score for
this player for today.
And similar for, this
is the high scorer
for the player for this
week, and for all time.
And if we're to look at the high
score for local player today,
these values are all null.
I don't believe this is
indicative of the fact
that this is the first time
I've submitted a score.
I believe these
values are always
set to null if what you've
submitted is a new high score.
So you'll either get the
Booleans equaled a yes,
or you will get, hey, this
is the current high score
for the player that
you do not beat.
Now, if we were to go back
and play this again-- let
me just show you something
here, let me play really fast.
Now, you'll notice that my
score report came back as null.
The entire thing is null.
This is a little
quirk with the system.
I've talked with
the team, I think
we're going to
change this behavior.
But what's happening
right now is
the system is smart
enough to know, one,
that this is a leaderboard
where the lower score is better,
and that I have just attempted
to submit a score that's
higher than what I
submitted just before.
In this case, the
system says, well, I'm
not going to bother submitting
this score of five guesses,
because I know that it's not
any better than the score four
that I submitted
just a minute ago.
The unfortunate
side effect of that,
is that I do not get a score
report when the library decides
that it's not going
to submit it for me.
I'd like to see us generate
a fake score report any way,
and hopefully that will happen.
But I guess that maybe the
main lesson to take away here
is, don't count on a score
report always existing.
You might need to check and
see if it's nil, and if it is,
take the appropriate actions.
So there you go.
If I were to stop this, by the
way, and run it again-- let's
try it again.
By the way, I can see myself
here, on the easy leaderboard,
both in my circles, and
in the public leaderboard.
I happen to be first,
that's fantastic.
So, let's play an
easy game here.
Now I do get back to
full score report.
And you can see that
my, hey, is this
a new high score for this player
for today, this week, all time,
are all set to zero.
And the high score for
the local player today
is now a GPGScore
object that has
things such as the
leaderboard ID, value,
and the formatted score,
and so on and so forth.
So you can take a look
at that, if you'd like.
Again, you can kind of raise
some interesting alerts
in your game based on that.
But, at least for
now until we change
the behavior of the
library, you can't
count on that score report
always existing, all the time.
So, anyway, there we go.
We've now submitted
scores to our leaderboard.
This is fantastic.
And if I had other
friends playing,
I'd start seeing them
in leaderboards as well.
Let's look at the next step
here in our application,
and that's going to be removing
this hard-coded string,
replacing it with an Enum.
Sort of like what we
did in the last chapter,
but I guess with one
minor difference,
and you'll find about that in
the next lesson See you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]